there was recent news about combatives
in the seal teams
what was the evolution towards mma
so the seal teams has gone through a
whole plethora
of various kind of hand-to-hand combat
type things when i when i first
came in there was something called
scars and i it stood for scientific
something something something something
but it was uh it sort of looked like a
kung fu yeah it was it was very um
actually i think it was based on on san
soo right
uh which is a martial art anyways so
that was kind of
when i showed up there then we kind of
morphed towards
something a little bit more modern and
then we morphed towards something else
and so
we were constantly kind of looking and
searching for something that was
efficient we ended up going with uh this
one this one contractor
for several years and you know so
use this this one contractor for several
years and then eventually
especially once the war started
and we had guys on a regular basis
doing hand-to-hand combat against the
enemy in front for those who don't
understand when that would happen
if we go into a building and there's
people in there that don't have weapons
well you can't just gun them all down
you have to get control of them
if their military age males you probably
got to cuff them you got to get them
down to the ground you got to control
them
now there's a whole variety of things
that can happen the guy can be
unarmed but literally combative you know
he can square up and say okay
it's on we've seen that and people might
be surprised to hear
that uh people actually do that you know
you got a gang of big tough seals there
they're gonna
gonna put you down we've had multiple
people like not comply
oh you're not gonna put me down and uh
it doesn't usually go too well for them
so that's that's one of the spectrum you
then you go
down the spectrum where it's someone
that just is scared and they're frozen
with fear
so but but you're yelling at them to get
down and arabic which is you know your
arabic's not great you're yelling at
them they're scared they freeze so now
what are you gonna do
you can't just stand there and keep
yelling at them you gotta get them to
the ground get them control so you
continue the clearance
then there's people that are gonna so
you've got all the way down to someone
that just you know you they see
they see you they put their hands up
they lay down that's great that's easy
so as we started getting into these
scenarios on a regular basis
we we realized that the system that had
been taught was
ineffective and that's and and also
luckily we had a bunch of guys in the
seal teams that were
into jiu-jitsu and muay thai wrestling
and mma in general
and so that kind of came in and
started people started saying hey why
don't you just do this
and this will actually get a person
under control and actually you told a
good story
uh to me today when we were talking
about jiu jitsu about that
that's a good that's a good little uh
explanation of where we were and where
we
where we got to in my first platoon we
went through that that training
uh and uh that was our prisoner handling
training so that's what that's what we
did and
and uh that's we we practice handling
prisoners and searching them and putting
them on the ground all that stuff
handling them
um and so you know we're told this is
the way to do it this is you know
well when we start going against role
players i remember one in particular um
we're going against we're in the kill
house and we're moving through
and of course we're this isn't live fire
you're going against role players
they're shooting back at you with
simunition which is a paint round
throughout
our actual weapons it's great training
because then you have then you have to
deal with people you have to actually
wrestle with people you actually have to
engage targets or they're shooting back
at you
outstanding training and we've talked
about that before but but
uh it is one of the things that really
stood out to me was i remember one
particular guy
one of the role players was a a pretty
large guy i mean he's probably six four
six
five like 250 pound guy big guy
and me and and this guy wasn't a seal he
wasn't a seal i think he was a gunners
mate or something he was just
volunteering to come up and be a role
player great
you know helps us with training um and
so you know a small role player you're
able to get them down to the ground
hold them and and uh you know get a
search on them
and um me and and another one of our
guys
who is a big a big guy this guy arms big
rounds my legs this seal was was
a large large man very strong guy and
we grabbed this guy we're trying to get
him the ground and he's not being
compliant
he's being he's resisting us and
it's hard i mean this this is difficult
for me and this other guy we're not
we're not small guys i mean we're
we're strong guys we're we're getting
this guy to the ground but he's not
cooperating we're having a hard time
keeping him down
another one of our guys who was actually
a lot smaller than us he was probably
180 pound guy i'm 200 pounds and
and the other sea i was describing it's
probably 230 pound guy
and uh his uh so this this
other seal comes up and he's like 180
pound guy
he's trained jiu jitsu he's got a little
bit of that he spent uh spent a little
time you know
at the gracie academy and and uh had was
one of the
one of the first guys i knew who who was
pretty pretty skilled in jiu jitsu and
and uh he he gets this this uh this big
guy that you know the role players
wrestling around that gunners made and
uh not cooperating we're wrestling
around with him he comes up there gets a
guy gets it gets a knee on him
goes like knee on stomach and
the guy the guy can't do anything and
you know here's this 180 pound guy
completely controlling this large guy
that two of us couldn't do before
and i was like i need to start training
some jiu jitsu because that stuff works
and it was just a it was just a reality
of like body control i can control this
guy i mean
neon stomach get his arms got him zip
tied done i mean he's
and he actually when we debrief with him
you know he he comes and now now he's
out of his role player realm and he's
like
he's like hey that was pretty cool and
then i think he actually probably
started training some jiu jitsu because
he
he he realized like just how effective
it was for a guy who
really understood body control to be
able to just get a knee on him hold him
down you know
and and be able to control him even
though he was half the size of this dude
interestingly
that's almost that's why most of us
start because they feel
it happens to you and you're like whoa
whoa whoa that was like
you're like how's this guy you know he
looks so much smaller than me and he's
just crushing me how's that possible
yeah
so that was you know and that that case
that you just described
happened like you know every day in the
seal team somebody else that that knew
some jiu-jitsu
you know would have that scenario happen
and eventually the the
the correct answer rises up and people
say hey look this is working
this is not working and so that's how we
ended up with uh
with more of an mma-based approach
because it's not just pure jiu-jitsu
it's everything it's muay thai it's
boxing it's
it's you know weapons retention pieces
to it
it's hitting people learning how to hit
people with your gun
what we call a muzzle strike which is
again this is one of those things where
we kind of would get be told that like
the muzzle strike
would would just kill people yeah it
would kill people or it's gonna
definitely incapacitate me instantly and
knock people out and
the fact of the matter isn't i know i
know leif and i have seen
i don't even know how many people i've
seen muscle strikes over and over and
over again
and it just the the amount i don't even
think i ever saw an actual knockout
i mean you see some damage it hurts and
it cuts the person's face open and it
makes them bleed everywhere and it's a
complete nightmare and you have to take
them to medical and
it's it's just a bad thing whereas
somebody that knows a little bit of mma
can go in and control these people and
take them down and it's
it's no factor so that's what ended up
taking over and
it's definitely a good thing and a
positive thing and it's been
it's been cool to talk to the guys that
are now carrying on with the program